the Communists full-court press that's
the focus of tonight's angle during the
nfl's colin kaepernick kneeling
controversy prominent NBA players came
to his defense and supported his efforts
the NBA also supported the Golden State
Warriors in 2018 when the league champs
announced they wouldn't make that
ceremonial trip to the White House as
long as Trump was in office politics
have always been part of players lives
and I'm proud of the fact in this league
that the players our coaches our owners
feel comfortable expressing their
political points of view well we learned
over the weekend the NBA supposedly
loved a free expression has its limits
the firestorm started on Friday when
Houston Rockets general manager Daryl
Morey tweeted this fight for freedom
stand with Hong Kong well that I'm not
get was tweet quickly drew the ire of
the Chinese communist regime their
tentacles reach right across the ocean
it quickly moved to hit the NBA where it
really hurts the pocketbook suspending
millions of dollars worth of franchise
business Beijing banned the Houston
Rockets games from Chinese TV
well the Rockets owner in the NBA got
the message and quickly grovelled to
their Chinese masters moving to censure
Maury for his tweet in Rockets player
James Harden who's in Tokyo for a team
practice bed the Chinese for forgiveness
apologized
you know we love try that we love no
playing there they show us the most
important love so you know we appreciate
as a fanbase and we love everything you
know they're about everything they're
about really well Maury who risk getting
permanently benched from management
dutifully obeyed and deleted his pro
Hong Kong tweet unbelievable even issued
an apology saying I did not intend my
tweet to cause any offense to rock its
fans and friends of mine in China I
would hope that those who are upset well
know that offending or misunderstanding
them was not my intention but the most
despicable reaction came from the NBA
itself the leak put out two apologies
count them one in English calling more
his tweet quote regrettable and then
another shameless statement in Chinese
reading they were extremely disappointed
in the inappropriate remarks made by
Houston Rockets general manager daryl
morey standing with the persecuted
people of Hong Kong is inappropriate
they should wear any criticism of the
Chinese regime as a badge of honor but
no can do you know I also think it's
funny to look back like 18 months or so
to the self-righteous pompous comments
of NBA coaches who have no trouble
trashing President Trump and even his
voters I think a bloviator 'he's like
Spurs head coach the uber liberal Gregg
Popovich I wonder what the people think
about who voted for him where their line
is where does the the morality and the
decency kick in one wonders what is in
their heads or country's and
embarrassment in the world no you're an
embarrassment Gregg if you have the
audacity to lecture us on morality as
your league is standing with one of the
most repressive regimes in the world are
you kidding me and did he speak out
today in support of Morrie I don't think
so no still waiting for that so you
speak to the end defend the rights of
players to trash Trump but when one of
his NBA
sends out a bland critique very bland of
one of the most horrific dictatorships
on the planet suddenly it's crickets
chirping everywhere we do live in a
difficult time we all know the situation
we all know why we all know where the
source is where a lot of the division
comes from because it's so obvious now
it's it's boring the bar has been
lowered so far well very prophetic bar
sure has been lowered when the NBA
stands more unequivocally for the hammer
and sickle than it does for the red
white and blue or is it just all about
money I remember this is the same league
that moved the 2017 NBA all-star game
out of Charlotte North Carolina over a
state law that prevented transgender
people from using whatever bathrooms
they didn't want it apparently that was
too much for the NBA but China stifling
free speech brutalizing political
dissidents Christians Muslims their
region camps apparently that's all fine
we love what they're all about
if the NBA wanted to use games as a tool
of social change wouldn't it be
appropriate to cancel the games in China
given their horrendous human rights
record their persecution and
imprisonment of dissidents and anyone
really who speaks their conscience and
perhaps against the ruling regime
wouldn't that be a nice change I never
imagined this could happen in the 21st
century
innocent people subjected to cuffs on
their hands shackles and black hoods
over their heads every day they toss us
a little bread and water so that we
didn't die and every day they would
interrogate 15 or 20 of us with
unbearable brutality as long as the NBA
gets its franchise fees okay by them
this is a barbaric regime this is a
dictatorship that controls how many
children couples can have force the
sterilization and abortion on women
aren't those endangered lives worthy of
a protest or just saying you know
money's good but we can't do it anymore
or we only cancel games over bathrooms
signage controversies the NBA is quick
to virtue signal when it costs them
nothing but the moment their Chinese
overlords Balch the cower in the corner
shut down any criticism make the mistake
China's treatment of the Rockets is a
warning shot to every professional
sports team and any American business
doing business in China play by their
rules or you will be punished just today
China scrubbed all social media
references and access to the show South
Park in their country this day after the
show dared to criticize China's mass
detention and torture programs
[Music]
I'm a proud member of the Communist
Party the party is more important than
the individual well in reaction of the
ban South Park creators Trey Parker and
Matt Stone issued this mock apology like
the NBA we welcome the Chinese censors
into our homes and into our hearts we
too love money more than freedom and
democracy
she doesn't look just like Winnie the
Pooh at all long live the great
Communist Party of China I made this
autumn Sargam harvest be bountiful we
good now China well that's the correct
response I stand by what I've said
before we should gradually
but seriously disentangle American
interests from Chinese interests until
they completely reform their ways
American brands American companies are
engaged in a demonic bargain in China
everyone in the 80s back when I was in
college when campus activists pushed the
entire entertainment industry to boycott
South Africa because of apartheid that
evil regime was divestment now banners
hung out of dorm windows all over campus
it wasn't a lot of money though to be
made in South Africa not really and the
value of billions in China is more
important though than the precious value
of free expression that the NBA claimed
it cherished next time the NBA tries to
virtue signal civil rights we're gonna
ask them why when they have the chance
to stand for universal values of free
speech free exercise of religion free
assembly they decided to cave to the
Communists and that's the angle